[Música]
los días pasa algo asesinar a alguien
secuestran a alguien y lo más triste es
que no se sabe por qué porque si fuese
que esto estuvieses sucediendo entre
armados pues uno dice allá de ellos pero
es que ya es con la población civil que
uno no entiende
esa es la preocupación grande
ayer la bandita no lo quito una guerra
donde nosotros no pedimos estar dónde
donde nosotros no hacemos parte de ese
conflicto entonces sentimos rabia dolor
es una situación de mini guerra regional
pero en una frontera caliente que
plantea retos también geopolíticos
porque en esto intervienen incluso otros
países que buscan calentar la frontera
para ganar posiciones en un escenario
mucho más amplio incluso a nivel
internacional
[Música]